Una pelota sale disparada hacia el aire desde el techo de un edificio que tiene 50 metros
de altura desde el piso.
Si su velocidad inicial es de 20 metros
por segundo y además la ecuación "h", "h" de
altura es igual a "-16t" cuadrada más "20t"
más 50, modela la altura de la pelota
después de "t" segundos.
¿En cuánto tiempo chocará la pelota en el suelo?
Y bueno, en varias listas de física que hacemos
en Kahn Academy podemos ver porqué esta ecuación
modela o describe el comportamiento de la
pelota al salir del techo, sería muy bueno
que tú revisaras estas listas algún día,
sin embargo en esta ocasión lo voy a dar
por hecho, nosotros sabemos que ésta es la
ecuación que modela la altura de la pelota
dado algún tiempo.
Y bueno, si te das cuenta que la pelota choque
con el suelo quiero decir que la altura se
haga 0 y si tenemos una ecuación de la altura,
lo que tenemos que hacer es resolver esta
ecuación, porque la altura vale 0, entonces
me queda que 0 es igual a "-16t" cuadra más
"20t" más 50 y lo que estoy buscando precisamente
es las "t" que cumplan esto.
Ahora date cuenta que todo es divisible entre
2 y de hecho, todo es divisible entre -2,
entonces lo que voy a hacer es dividir todo
entre -2 para que "t" cuadrada me quede positivo,
-16 entre -2 me da 8, "8t" cuadrada
y después 20 entre menos 2 me da "-10t" y después más
50 entre -2 me da -25 y ya tengo una ecuación
cuadrática igual a 0.
Está en su posición estándar o si quieres
lo podemos ver así, tachamos esto e igualamos
aquí a 0 y estamos en su posición estándar,
por lo tanto, podemos completar el el dilema
al cuadrado perfecto o hacer lo que se nos
ocurra, pero también podemos aplicar la fórmula
cuadrática y en esta ocasión vamos a aplicar
la fórmula cuadrática y para esto necesitamos
saber cual es el valor de "a", que por cierto
es el que está al lado de la "t" cuadrada,
cual es el valor de "b" que por cierto es
el que está al lado de la "t" y cual es el
valor de "c".
Aquí tenemos que "a" vale 8, "b" vale -10
y "c" vale -25 y que por cierto, la fórmula
cuadrática me dice que la solución es en
este caso que son "t", son de la forma "-b"
más menos la raíz cuadrada de "b" cuadrada
menos "4ac" entre "2a".
Por lo tanto, lo único que hay que hacer
es sustituir los valores de "a", "b" y "c"
en esta ecuación, "t" es igual a "-b" pero
menos por menos me va a dar más,
entonces me queda 10 más menos la raíz cuadrada de
"b" cuadrada, es decir de -10 al cuadrado
lo cual me da 100, -4 por "a" que es 8, por
"c" que es -25, -4 por 8 por -25,
todo esto dividido entre dos veces "a", 2 por 8 es lo
mismo que 16 y bueno pues vamos a simplificar
lo más que se pueda toda esta ecuación,
-4... menos por menos me da más, entonces esto
se va y me queda 4 por 8 = 32, 32 por 5, bueno,
esto es lo mismo que 4 por 25 que es 100 por
8 me da 800, entonces me va a quedar que esto
es lo mismo que 10 más menos la raíz cuadrada
de 900 entre 16 y 900 tiene raíz cuadrada
exacta, esto es 30, entonces me queda 10 más
menos 30 que es la raíz cuadrada de 900 entre 16.
Y bueno, entonces aquí ya tengo mis dos soluciones,
la primera es con signo más 10 más 30 que
es 40 entre 16 y aquí puedo simplificar puedo
sacar cuarta tanto arriba como abajo, me queda
10 entre 4, de hecho puedo simplificar más
puedo sacar octava y me queda 5 entre 2, 5/2.
Y ahora me voy a fijar con el signo menos
y me queda que "t" es igual a 10 menos 30,
lo cual me da -20, 20 entre 16
y aquí puedo sacar mitad, de hecho si puedo sacar cuarta y me queda -5 sobre 4
y bueno, ya tenemos dos soluciones para "t", pero no hay que perder de vista la idea de que "t" es el tiempo y
estamos hablando de un problema físico , entonces
no podemos tener tiempos negativos,
no podemos tener que "t" valga -5/4, esto no tiene sentido por lo tanto el valor que en verdad soluciona
este problema físico es "t" igual a 5/2 que
es lo mismo que 2.5, que por cierto no olvidemos
las unidades, son 5/2 segundos ó 2.5 segundos,
lo que me da de respuesta este problema físico...
que ahorita no me voy a meter en problemas
físicos, de pensar porqué esta es la solución
en la cual la pelota choca con el suelo y
lo si voy a hacer es verificar que en efecto,
ésta sea la solución que me dé esto igual a 0.
Por lo tanto, vamos a comprobar y para esto
me voy a agarrar la ecuación original
y voy sustituir el valor de "t" por 5/2 y me queda
-16, que multiplica a "t" cuadrada, es decir
a 5/2 elevados al cuadrado, más 20 por "t",
es decir, más 20 por 5/2, más 50 y esto
tiene que ser igual a 0.
Y vamos a ver, -16... 5 al cuadrado me da
25 y a esto le tengo que dividir entre 4,
2 por 2 es 4 y aquí me queda, 20 entre 2
me da 10, 10 por 5 me da 50, entonces es más
50, más 50 y esto tiene que ser igual a 0.
Y ahora, a continuación voy a decir -16 entre
4 me da -4, -4 por 25 es lo mismo que -100,
100 negativo más 50...
espera, espera, espera, es -100, -100 más
50 más 50 igual a 0, no olvidemos los signos
y dice 100 negativo más 50 más 50 pues esto
claramente es 0, 0 es igual a 0 y por lo tanto
ya tenemos la comprobación.
Cuando nosotros tenemos el tiempo igual a 5/2 o a 2.5 segundos, se cumple que la pelota choca con el suelo.
Y además, este tiempo cumple que tiene un sentido completamente lógico y físico.